hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast of informing clinical
interpretations of structural chromosome
rearrangements implementing evolving
knowledge from chromatin structure I'm
Cynthia Morton I'm a professor at
Harvard Medical School and the director
of cytogenetics at Brigham and Women's
Hospital we are delighted to bring you
this educational web seminar presented
by lab roots lab roots is the leading
scientific social networking website and
producer of educational virtual events
and webinars before we begin I'd like to
remind everyone that this event is
interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want at any time you
want during the presentation just click
on the ask a question box located on the
far left of your screen and type your
questions into the drop-down box that
appears on the screen I will be
answering questions via email after our
live presentation if you have trouble
seeing or hearing the presentation
please click on the help desk button
located in the promotional board at the
bottom center of your screen or use the
ask a question box to let us know that
you're having a problem without further
ado I will now begin today's
presentation it's been my pleasure
to have a professional career as a
clinical saito geneticist at Brigham and
Women's Hospital there were some days
though that were less than satisfying
when I had to deliver information to a
patient which was less clear than we
would have liked it to have been but
those days are changing now we have much
more information about our genome from
the Human Genome Project and I'm going
to share with you how that has changed
the type of information we can give to
individuals with chromosome
rearrangements in today's presentation
I'll first speak about chromatin
organization and human disorders through
the perspective
of constitutional balanced chromosome
rearrangements and in particular discuss
disrupted genes and dysregulated genes
secondly I'll talk about computational
prediction of position effects
non-coding chromosome rearrangements and
our analysis strategy so you might want
to know why is the evolving knowledge of
genome organization important for a
clinical site Oh geneticists how can
this information impact diagnosis and
prognosis in the clinical laboratory
today and how might an understanding of
genome structure play into future
treatments for patients I want to
introduce you to a project that my
laboratory fondly knows as d gap for the
developmental genome Anatomy project the
hypothesis of this project is that
chromosomal rearrangements in
individuals with congenital anomalies
can be etiologic in the abnormal
phenotype due to disruption or
dysregulation of genes critical in human
development this is a paradigm of human
genetics from which we have made many
gene discoveries this is an overview of
the D gap study design we begin with a
blood sample from a patient who has been
identified to have a structural
chromosome rearrangement we then employ
whole genome sequencing jumping
libraries a next-generation sequencing
method to identify the rearrangement
breakpoints we sequence across the
breakpoints to nucleotide level
precision to identify candidate genes
and then we validate those candidate
genes by a number of methods including
animal and cellular models and nowadays
doing quite a bit of our analysis and
validation by database mining for gene
function
now I'm a real fan of genome-wide
Association studies where we no longer
have to look under the lamppost to find
the gene that we're interested in but in
this particular project it turns out all
the keys are under the lamppost
so the chromosomal rearrangements
provide the signpost for us for the gene
of interest in the disorder here's just
an overview of the jumpring library
methodology that we use it's a
traditional next-generation sequencing
library method with the exception that
the inserts that we use are a bit larger
so if you look on the bottom row you can
see a 2 KB fragment which is bounded by
the red and green rectangles which are
indicating different portions of a
chromosome which may involve be involved
in a reef in a rearrangement so this is
a read which includes a portion from two
different chromosomes as you would have
in a chromosomal translocation what
we're looking for our sequences in reads
that are not aligned to the reference
genome so a model would be that
chromosome a and chromosome B are found
on the same sequencing reads so that
tells us that we've crossed the
chromosomal breakpoint whether it's a
translocation or an inversion and then
we're able to design PCR primers to go
in and sequence directly across that to
resolve the chromosomal rearrangement to
nucleotide level precision here's a
summary of the different genes that we
have found in chromosomal rearrangements
over the 15 years of the project you may
note that some are indicated by blue
font these are the ones that were the
original time of the project when we
didn't have next-generation sequencing
and you can see then those in red and
green which have all been found since we
were able to employ next-generation
sequencing methods so you will notice
that they are on all the different human
chromosomes so there's no chromosome
that is specifically more likely to be
in a rearrangement as the in in this
patients that we have analyzed so I want
to talk to you to exemplify the changes
that are occurring in our ability to
interpret cases by one of my favorite
cases which we'll call D gap 103d gap
103 involves a chromosomal inversion a
Perry centric inversion involving the
centromere in one of the homologues of
chromosome 12 that you'll see on the
right side of the screen so there's a
simple apparently balanced inversion the
patient had the following clinical
features and this patient a male as
you'll notice from the cytogenetic
nomenclature underneath the cartoon
cartoons of chromosome 12 and also
you'll note from that nomenclature that
this is a de novo chromosome
rearrangement meaning that neither of
his parents carried this rearrangement
so this individual came into our study
when he was about 8 years old with the
clinical features of multiple lipomas
overgrowth which had been noted by his
parents since about two months of age so
greater than the 95th percentile
arthritis advanced dental and bone ages
bilateral bowing of legs brachydactyly
of hands and feet and facial dismorphism
so I think you'll agree that these
aren't typical findings that you would
see in an eight-year-old here's the
picture of D gap 103 and you can perhaps
a pre appreciate the dental overgrow
in the center picture these lumps that
you see on his legs are lipomas and then
there is the histology associated with
the lipomas in the bottom you'll see on
the left side the enlarged joints and
the brachydactyly in the middle the
bowing of the legs and then in the
radiographs the flared
pithos ease so DTaP 103 has his own
Wikipedia page and he's known at the
time of this Wikipedia posting for being
the tallest teenager on earth and at
that point when he was about 14 years
old he was seven feet four and a half
inches tall at that time his
endocrinologist arrested his growth by
treatment with high-dose testosterone so
here's D gap 103 entering Children's
Hospital with his mother and his half
sibling I think you'll appreciate his
height and you can still see on his legs
the lumps that are from the lipomas and
the facial dismorphism including the
dental overgrowth and in this particular
picture reminds me to tell you that he
had had 12 additional molars taken out
in the previous year you'll see his
fingers now as a 14 year old where the
the digits are short still and the the
fingers are enlarged but on the bottom
you'll see why he was entering the
hospital
here's his spleen which was about the
size of a football and the normal size
would be somewhere around the size of
your fist so this was a surgery that was
performed to be sure that he wouldn't
get into any type of life-threatening
situation from
perhaps being hit in the belly
accidentally and having a bleed from
this spleen so it turns out that we were
able to map the break point of his
rearrangement on chromosome 12 on the
long arm into a region at band cue 14.3
which harbors the gene hm GA - we were
not surprised at all that this is a gene
that was involved in his overgrowth
syndrome because this is a gene which we
had been studying in the laboratory for
its involvement in a very common tumor
in women known as uterine fibroids and
these tumors have display overgrowth and
we certainly see that there's an
overgrowth syndrome that's underway with
this chromosome rearrangement one of the
things we need to do and the D gap
project is to validate that the gene
that we implicate by our sequencing is
actually the gene that's involved and
that we don't have the situation where
the finding is true that there is a
chromosome rearrangement and that the
individual has a phenotype but they're
unrelated so we look for various lines
of evidence and in this particular case
we were able to validate the findings of
limpo lipomas and overgrowth by the fact
that they have both been observed in two
mouse models with HMG a2 truncation and
i might mention that HMG a2 is also
recognized as etiologic in some in human
lipomas as well he also as you know had
an arthritic symptoms and we have
evidence that HMG a2 is rearranged
Insano via of patients some patients
with osteoarthritis what was also
interesting were findings that came
post us publishing this paper in which
variants in HM GA to were found to
influence human height and this was from
a genome-wide Association study which
involved night over nineteen thousand
adults from four other studies in
children and a tall short case control
study HM GA two is recognized to explain
about 0.3 percent of population
variation in height so I often like to
say to my G wasps colleagues well you
know this study required over 19,000
individuals and in some cases such as
this valuable information can be
obtained from one patient so this is
really an an in of one finding that this
gene is very important in influencing
human height well there was one part of
that phenotype that really didn't sit
very well with our findings and that was
the finding of brachydactyly I was
really fortunate in my life to have the
opportunity to serve as the editor of
the American Journal of Human Genetics
and one afternoon a paper appeared in on
my desk from the laboratory of Stefan
Mun Lohse entitled deletion and point
mutations of PT h LH caused
brachydactyly type d well I knew this
gene because it was the gene that was
telomeric to the breakpoint on the short
arm of chromosome 12 and it's located as
you can see in the breakpoints above at
12 P 12.1 to p1 1.2 so we had looked in
the regions of the inversion to be sure
that there might not be a fusion
transcript and this was the gene that
was the closest to that short arm
breakpoint so now it seemed very likely
that
the etiology of d gap 103 s
brachydactyly had to do with
dysregulation of parathyroid hormone
like hormone well how do we think about
dis regulation of genes it's easy to
sort of understand a gene that's
disrupted and that might change the
expression abrogate the expression of
that particular gene but but what about
genes that are not actually at the
breakpoints and I was fortunate actually
to be in the audience at the American at
the excuse me European Society of Human
Genetics meeting in 2015 when a paper
also coming from Stephan Manolos lab was
presented which was entitled disruptions
of topological chromatin domains cause
pathogenic rewiring of gene enhancer
interactions this paper made it clear to
me that we needed to look in the
neighborhood of our chromosomal
rearrangements such as looking in the
neighborhood that would have included
parathyroid hormone like hormone to
explain the phenotypes and I highly
recommend this paper it it was such an a
moment for me in terms of thinking about
relooking at many cases that we had
already studied and I was anxious to get
back to my laboratory in Boston and try
to understand some of these cases better
so this leads me just to remind you that
our genome is has a is highly structured
and that chromosomes live in territories
and you can see them sort of indicated
as different colored entities in in the
nucleus and this actually had been
recognized for some time by
cytogeneticist who used chromosome
painting methods and saw that there was
a non-random positioning of chromosomes
nucleus well we've now become able to
recognize that below this level at a
higher level of resolution in the 10
mega base to 1 mega base region we have
chromatin organized in something known
as topological associating domains and
that'll be an important part of the rest
of this presentation and then that when
we look at the even further a higher
resolution there is our chromatin is
organiz organized into loops in which
the blue coding sequence of the gene
which is preceded by its promoter region
is interacting with an enhancer region
that is involved in regulating that gene
so we have a a really highly organized
genome and if you look to the left side
on on the screen you'll see again the
colors in the nucleus and then a
schematic of the chromatin which is
unwound or less highly condensed sort of
the spaghetti lines that you see on the
in beyond on the figure on the left and
then below a schematic of the
interaction of inside a topological
domain which is bounded by these purple
structures and then genes inside the
that tent which are regulated by various
elements so let's think about what
happens when you have a chromosomal
rearrangement such as an inversion which
we saw in d gap 103 so the there are two
tabs in the top of the figure on the on
the in the wild-type situation or
cartoon on the right and you can see
that there are genes inside the tad on
the
the tad B which has an enhancer that's
turning on gene one well if we and the
Tad's are separated by boundary regions
or TBR's as we sometimes call them and
then if there were an inversion such
that you flip around part of the tad on
the right with the tad on the left
you'll see that the enhancer element is
now able to interact with gene - and the
is no longer able to interact with gene
one so it's regulating the wiring of the
genome by its structural organization
and the same type of different elements
can go on in terms or mechanism dope can
go on with duplications deletions if you
saw a deletion that was wholly inside
the tad and didn't disrupt the boundary
region there as on the very bottom of
this diagram you can see that in fact
there might not might not be any effect
on the expression of the gene so the
disruption of the trad structure rewires
gene expression so just a little more
information on Tad's again these tad
stands for topological associating
domains these are mega based sized
genomic segments and they partition our
genome into large regulatory units that
have frequent intradomain chromatin
interactions but relatively rare inter
domain interactions so the interactions
are in chad a are more frequent than
they any interactions from a would be
with tat be their conserved across
different cell types and species
considered crucial for spatio-temporal
gene expression patterns and they're
separated as I mentioned by these TBR's
the
illogical boundary regions which block
the interactions between adjacent Tad's
we've learned that disruption of the TBR
by structural rearrangements causes
rewiring of genomic regulators that may
result in abnormal phenotypes so let's
go back and think about the D gap 103
phenotype and the finding of
brachydactyly which I felt must be
mediated by an effect on parathyroid
hormone like hormone that was located
telomeric to the breakpoint on the short
arm of the chromosome 12 of course I
told you that I was familiar with that
gene when I saw it come across my desk
in a manuscript for review because we
had looked for a fusion transcript with
a part of H mga - but had not found that
so below you can see a schematic of the
tad and with the boundary elements
indicated in grey on each end and the
position of the breakpoint on the short
arm of chromosome 12 within a within the
tab that includes parathyroid hormone
like hormone so everything seemed to be
falling into place to really reinforce
that this gene was dis regulated and was
the etiology of brachydactyly in d cap
103 now we looked also at the genes that
were in around a four mega base region
of the breakpoint and you can see that
I've highlighted parathyroid hormone
like hormone it's the only gene in that
area which is known or predicted to have
a gene dosage in effect and and of
course this is information that's
derived from manuscripts like that which
came from the mon los lab where was
known that inactivation of this gene
would result in the clinical phenotype
of a breaking down
actually so now we had a whole new way
of assessing chromosome rearrangements
and trying to predict or understand the
phenotypes that we observed I want to
talk to you about another case that's
been the subject of one of my graduate
students work Sam schilit who's smiling
faces
looking at you from the screen on the
bottom of the right hand of the screen
so she has taken on the study of all ago
sperm 'ya in a twenty-year-old 28 year
old white male who presented with a
two-year history of infertility and a
sperm count less than two million per
mil he had no other dysmorphic features
and had normal stature normal FSH LH and
testosterone and had a normal semen
semen volume he had had a very good work
up by his physician in addition the
physician had requested a cytogenetic
analysis and it was found that he had a
translocation involving chromosomes 20
and 22 in addition he had an array CGH
assay performed and that was um
determined to be within normal limits
and in addition as part of his genetic
testing it was determined that there was
no Y chromosome deletion in the azf
regions and he was negative for any
mutation in the Cystic Fibrosis gene the
CFTR gene you can see on the right the
schematics of the chromosomes and the
derivative xx and the derivative 22
which have exchange segments that appear
to be balanced at the level of routine
cytogenetic testing so the next step was
to actually define those breakpoints two
nucleotide level resolution which we did
with the jumping library method
and then describe that break point on
the to rearrangement to derivative
chromosomes and you can see the next
generation cytogenetic nomenclature
which was the work of a very gifted
postdoc in the labs era or to Lou and
you can see Zehra Zehra soto on this
slide as well so now we can actually
describe we can make a method to
actually describe the the rearrangement
of the chromosome at a at a level that
includes
precision down to nucleotide level so
the next question for us was really what
was disrupted or potentially
dysregulated and it turns out that there
was a disruption of a gene and you can
see on the chromosome 20 in the tab to
the to the on the left side of the
figure there's a line drawn through this
genes TD h4 we thought a lot about CD h4
and didn't really have a good model for
how this might impact his fertility and
we sort of put the case aside for a
while and of course that was before we
knew about Tad's and you can see that
the breakpoint that occurred on the 22
in this large pink tab was actually
outside of any coding gene so my
graduate student Sam was very clever and
did an experiment I would have never
told her to do but that's what the the
beautiful thing about graduate students
is they they think beyond their mentors
and in this case she decided to look at
the to do a PCR experiment of all the
genes that were in the Tad's to assess
their expression and you won't note
right away there's a very large height
of the bar over the last gene in the TAT
on chromosome 20 and that's a gene that
has the gene symbol C
ptoo well this was a really interesting
gene because it's a gene that's
expressed in male meiosis and it now has
been potentially dysregulated by the
chromosome rearrangement and you can I
should also tell you that the the cells
that were testing or lymphoblastoid cell
lines and the controls are basically age
and sex matched individuals with who are
carry stereotypically normal so there
was a huge increase in the expression
relative f6p to relative to the control
lymphoblastoid cell lines and sic p2 is
really has an appreciable expression in
lymphoblastoid cell lines and is really
8/8 estes expressed transcript so this
was pretty surprising and pretty
interesting because this is a gene that
was really interesting from the
standpoint of meiosis and potentially
fertility so one thing that Sam did was
to establish that the expression from
sick p2 was coming specifically from the
from one allele that this allele had
been up regulated due to the chromosomal
rearrangement so you can see on the top
that the sequencing chromatograms from
both sick p2 and gap th where you see
that there is their polymorphisms and
then that there are different variants
on the two alleles and when you prepare
RNA from the cell line you find that
there's only that you you don't see any
polymorphism in the SiC p2 chromatogram
because all the transcript is coming
from one allele yet in the gap th you
also see see the same um
out of variation as you see in the
chromatogram from the DNA tracing so you
look you know comparing the DNA of sick
p2 with the RNA you see that we don't
see any variation indicating that the
transcript is coming from one allele
well then she decided not only do we
need to establish that it's coming from
one allele but we need to know that it's
coming from the allele that is involved
with the chromosome rearrangement and
the rearrangement was at some distance
from this gene so she developed a method
using proximity ligation to identify
that through hi-c technologies that the
transcript came about from positioning
of sequence from chromosome 22 near to
SiC p2 that would allow transcript from
the derivative xx allele and you'll see
that again below that the the DNA
sequence is polymorphic the RNA sequence
and the derivative xx transcript
sequence match identically so this is
proving that the abnormal transcript is
coming from the the chromosome that's
involved in the in the rear chromosome
rearrangement well this is an
interesting gene as I said it encodes
synaptic animal complex to protein and
this is a protein that's involved in
prophase one in meiosis and it's
involved in the pairing of homologous
chromosomes positioning them for genetic
recombination through crossing over so
it's a very important protein in in
human male meiosis so to just leave that
story at this point I will tell you that
there are some many exciting experiments
ongoing in the lab to
look at the possibility and what we feel
is the likely origin that there is an
enhancer adoption so an enhancer that is
coming into the vicinity through the
rearrangement of the tab to upregulate
SiC p2 we don't have the opportunity to
test this in the test this in the testes
because the tissue is not available but
it seems likely that that would be the
etiology of the upregulation so like to
move you now to think about how we might
use this information in prenatal
cytogenetics so if you like if you'll
accept prenatal next gen cytogenetics
i'm gonna tell you about ten pregnancies
with balanced rearrangements all ten
were high-risk pregnancies either
because of advanced maternal age or an
abnormal maternal screen or ultrasound
and nine were known to be de novo
rearrangements the 10th one we never
received the information to confirm that
it was a de novo rearrangement and
typically the way we handle these in the
clinical cytogenetics laboratory is to
rely on a publication from Dorothy
Warburton who was a wonderful clinical
site of geneticist and she published a
paper in early 1990s looking at the risk
of an untoward outcome from the
diagnosis of a de novo apparently
balanced rearrangement in a preemie in
the prenatal setting and then seeing
what happened at delivery and the risk
of an untoward outcome that we still
quote today for a translocation is 6.1%
and and for an inversion 9.4% so the
cases that I'll describe for you
a selection of the
cases all had normal array CGH so no
indication that the chromosome
rearrangement itself resulted in any
deletion or duplication in in repairing
the the broken chromosomes that have
exchanged segments so now as I said we
can move to studying these
rearrangements at nucleotide level
precision so to just summarize the 10
prenatal cases before describing some of
them in detail the predicted outcomes of
our sequence analysis and analysis and
interpretation and this was prior to us
being able to think about the the
structure of chromatin especially the
tad structure in these chromosomes in
terms of making the interpretation so we
predicted three were likely to have
normal outcomes and five were abnormal
one was from disruption of the C hd7
gene that's consistent with syndrome
known as charge syndrome one
dysregulation of sox9 consistent with
the phenotype of Pierre Robin sequence
one dysregulation of igf2 which is known
in silver Russel syndrome one a MTM one
dysregulation that could explain an
intrauterine fetal demise and then
another case with sonic hedgehog and mdf
to see dis regulation in a very complex
chromosomal rearrangement involving a
4-way rearrangement and a two-way
rearrangement consistent with a
chromothripsis in which there were
notably cerebral malformation and a
hypoplastic corpus callosum the outcomes
or decisions of these cases that I these
cases included two terminations and one
of those was a case that we would have
made a prediction of a normal outcome
and one of an abnormal outcome so there
was a disruption of protein coding genes
in three cases one was the CH d7 gene in
charge syndrome
one was khd RB 3 which is known which we
predicted to be a variant of uncertain
significance and this was before we
again would be able to interpret it
based on the tab and I will talk to you
a little bit more about that case and
then one RFC 3 which is variant also we
predicted of uncertain clinical
significance and significance which
would have been predicted to have a
potential tat effect then there were
genes that appear dysregulated with
known long-range regulatory regions such
as Sox 9 and the s HH and mes to see and
then there are some other dysregulated
regions that I'll talk to you about
which occurred in non-genic regions of
the genome so here's the first case D
gap 239 this was came from a 38 year old
who had had a history of infertility
this was her second pregnancy and it was
a much desired pregnancy following IVF
she had normal first trimester screening
but about nineteen weeks it was noted
that there was tricuspid atresia and
hypoplastic right ventricle and between
that time and 27 weeks there were
multiple appointments with pediatric
cardiologist and pediatric cardiology
cardi cardiac surgeons to consider
repair of the heart defect at 27 weeks
the picture became a bit more morbid
with polyhydramnios and in
detected stomach i should mention that
the patient was offered the opportunity
to have an invasive procedure for a
definitive diagnosis of the amniotic
fluids cell
chromosome karyotyping and had declined
that in part because this was a very
precious pregnancy and the couple didn't
want to take a chance of disrupting the
pregnancy at 33 weeks again the
situation became more morbid with flexed
extremities a protruding upper lip and
micrognathia and that at that point the
initiation of multiple therapeutic amnio
reductions and karyotyping and it was at
that time that a sample was received in
the cytogenetics lab for karyotyping and
what we found was that there was an
apparently balanced rearrangement
between chromosome 6 and chromosome 8
and you'll see the 8 breakpoint q13
indicated in green type and that's a
theme that will be present in the next
few slides in which that's the original
assignment by the cytogenetics lab but
by karyotype by by sequencing analysis
you can see that we refined the
breakpoint and that has occurred
commonly when we sequence rearrangements
two nucleotide level present 8 precision
so the breakpoint is now at positioned
at Q 12.2 so in the ideograms on the
right you can see the green area which
corresponds to the break points by
cytogenetics so that's the range of that
area of the genome but of course once
you sequence the rearrangements you can
just draw a line precisely where that
break point occurs and you'll see in the
derivative chromosome 8 on the right
that the the breakpoint is occurring in
ch d7 the breakpoint on chromosome 6
also disrupted a gene LM BRD 1
and based on our assessment of the
potential phenotype of that we believe
that it was not involved in the clinical
phenotype at 35 weeks there was again
another clinical phenotype of
undescended testes and the clinical
diagnosis that was received at birth was
charge syndrome so we gave this
information which was consistent with
the clinical phenotype but now we can go
back and relook at this case with
respect to the structural organization
of the genome and the tab and I will
tell you that this baby passed away at
10 days after delivery so we use even
with before cats the convergent genomic
analysis information so any any
information we can get about clinical
phenotype but of course in this
particular case it was well recognized
that a disruption of CHD 7 accounted for
the clinical phenotype so you can see
above in the horizontal bars that were
presenting under both derivative
chromosomes the derivative of chromosome
6 and the derivative of chromosome 8 and
the Tad's structure is given above a
schematic of what the the chromosome
would be like with the 2 derivative the
2 portions of the two different
chromosomes involved in the chromosomal
rearrangement so you'll see above that
in chromosome 6 the blue line is drawn
through LMB Rd 1 indicating its
disruption and also in Ch D 7 so now we
look at the tad structure there and our
interpretation is that there were no
additional genes which would be
expressed expected to have a dosage
effect or imprinted genes that would
then be contributing to the abnormal
phenotype other than CH d7 and
which charge syndrome is
well-established and below you can see
the next generation cytogenetic
nomenclature that we use to describe
this chromosome rearrangement to
nucleotide level so this seems to be
that the interpretation was pretty much
spot-on without any other additions to
this based on looking at the tad
structure so I'll take you to the next
case this is D gap two forty seven forty
one-year-old this was her third
pregnancy she it was at sixteen weeks
she had a normal first trimester
screening and the karyotype revealed a
de novo para centric inversion inversion
in the long arm of chromosome eight and
as you'll not be surprised as I've
alluded to we often end up changing the
breakpoints modifying them revising them
once we have the sequence analysis and
in this particular case again you see in
the ideogram those large areas indicated
in green shading that would would be
consistent with the breakpoint
resolution from cytogenetics and then in
where the red horizontal lines are where
where the sequencing provides precision
so in this case there was a breakpoint
in a non-genic region on the proximal
portion of the long arm and then in a
gene known as khd RB s 3 on the distal
end of the long arm and this khd RB s 3
is an RNA binding protein that
participates in regulating alternative
splicing our genetic counseling for this
finding with convergent genetic genomic
evidence led us to think that this could
be consistent with a normal clinical
outcome and that's where that that's the
information we provided and then when
the baby was born we were able to obtain
a cord blood sample and you can see in
the red bars is the x
Russian level of the patient and then in
and actually we got the core blood on
the bottom you can see comparison for to
a normal cord blood and then actually
above in age and sex matched amniotic
fluid cell culture so there definitely
is a decrease or if sorry a decrease in
the expression of khd our ps3 but it you
might consider that in the context of
many genes in the genome which one copy
is sufficient and perhaps that's what we
were predicting in this potential case
so when we did the chat analysis again
the same structure here with this slide
with a derivative the chromosome
rearrangement in in the two sites on in
this case an inversion on Chrome in the
long arm of chromosome eight where the
breakpoint lands in a non-genic region
in the proximal portion but you know in
the distal port region of the chromosome
in the inversion you can see the line
drawn through khd RB s 3 we in the tat
analysis we didn't review did not reveal
any mono allelic or imprinted genes that
we would expect to be associated with an
abnormal phenotype other than khd RB s 3
which you can imagine we were really
happy to have that conclusion at this
point so that we didn't wouldn't have
predicted that there would be any other
abnormal phenotypes that we didn't
discuss with the couple and again you
see the nomenclature that we designed to
report the chromosome rearrangements to
nucleotide level so here's the third
case this is a 44 year-old g1 at 12
weeks this was an unplanned pregnancy
and the it was in had normal first
trimester screening
the karyotype revealed a chromosome
translocation involving chromosomes 2
and 13 you can see this rearrangement it
was apparently balanced and was
determined to be de novo and then as we
have described previously the the green
areas indicate the resolution of the
cytogenetics and you can see the red
lines indicate where the sequencing
analysis allowed us to provide
resolution so one breakpoint was in a
non-genic region on the derivative 2 and
on the derivative 13 chromosome you can
see that there's a line drawn through a
gene known as RFC 3 RFC 3 is an
accessory protein that participates in
the elongation in DNA replication known
as a clamp loader so when we made the
call to schedule the discussion about
our findings we learned that the
pregnancy had been had already been
terminated prior to our communication of
the sequencing results we were a little
disheartened about that because we felt
that in this this was an example of a
case where we couldn't find any any
human pathology associated with our FC 3
haploinsufficiency or disruption and so
we would have been again interpreting it
as a variant of uncertain clinical
significance but with some belief that
in fact it could be associated with a
normal clinical finding so then we went
on to we looked at the expression of RFC
3 and this was a CVS sample and you can
see that the level of expression of the
gene in this d up to 48 case was below
that seen in age and sex matched CVS
samples so there would it be expected to
be less than the average level of
transcript of this
and then we did the TAT analysis and
this was every I often say every one of
these cases teaches us something new in
this particular case you can see the
again the blue vertical line disrupting
our fc3 and and no genes involved in the
upper portion where a chromosome 2 is
present so there were was no disruption
of any region that we were concerned
about however in addition to our FC 3
which is likely to be mono allelic in
this case that as you saw with the the
expression studies and but there but
again not interpreted to necessarily be
associated with any abnormal human
phenotype the breakpoints in the tab are
at in 13q 13.2 are 97 973 kilobases
upstream to NB EA which is a candidate
hap low insufficient gene for autism and
this is located within the same 2.16
Megabass tad with the breakpoints so you
can imagine that this was brought us to
a level of concern about the situation
that would have occurred for us if we
had had this information and been in a
position of providing that information
to the couple something that certainly
couldn't be assessed in the prenatal
situation and something that we know
that in the future we will be in a
position of trying to figure out how to
handle providing this information to
inform the couple but also making it
clear of the fact that this room would
remain a variant of uncertain
significance
so now I just like to talk to you a bit
about what happens when the D gap
breakpoints are in non-coding regions
and in particular in cases in which both
breakpoints are in non-coding regions at
this time in the study we had looked at
a we had sequenced 151 cases 17 didn't
overlap genes linked rnas or pseudogenes
they were 17 cases in non-coding regions
of the 17 15 cases were referred with
normal clinical micro arrays and to
their no array no clinical array had
been performed when the specimen was
referred so you can see where these 17
cases are located and we indicated where
both break points of the rearrangement
or present so this was picked up as a
project of a a also very talented
postdoc Cynthia is a Pettit Mendoza and
in collaboration with Jonas I didn't say
alum who had been working with Peter
Robinson so that the schematic of the
DNA sample is shown above from a
chromosome with enhancers genes ctcf
binding sites which are associated with
the tabs and the types of chromatin
contacts and what we decided to do in
this case you see the the balanced
chromosome abnormality breakpoint in the
red vertical line dotted line is
disrupting a region that is is non-genic
so Cynthia designed a approach to look
at the Tad's and to look at regions both
to encompassing two mega bases around
the breakpoint and up to six mega bases
around each of these breakpoints and
look at regulatory information including
enhancer annotation
and dnase hypersensitive sites then the
chromatin conformation
Tad's and interactions from hi-c
analyses and enhancer promoter contacts
and then clinical data whether the gene
whether they were genes predicted to
have a gene dosage effect through
haploinsufficiency and then to take the
findings of the clinical case and use
the human phenotype ontology fee no fee
no match scores and see if she could
develop an algorithm with this
information that would lead to some
prediction of a particular gene in the
clinical phenotype so this is the just a
summary of her work in predicting of the
17 cases eleven present potential
position effect so you can see the
karyotypes of the cases listed whether
any functional elements were disrupted
and whether the breakpoints fell within
Tad's in a couple different cells cell
lines and sources of DNA which have been
assessed for for tad structure and then
top ranking candidate genes which are
identified either in blue type because
they are predicted to have a recessive
phenotype or Klinge in there they're
annotated in Klinge in others which
underline our particular ones where
there may be a haploinsufficiency
phenotype so we gained quite a lot of
information from this and I'll show you
how we went ahead and applied this
information in one of the prenatal cases
so this was D gap 288 this was a 36 year
old female at this was her third
pregnancy at 12 weeks and there had been
abnormal fetal ultrasounds in this
pregnancy cystic hygroma identified at
11 weeks
micrognathia at 18 weeks and the
karyotype was performed indicated a
balance de novo chromosome rearrangement
between chromosomes 6 and 17 and then as
you're familiar now a revision of the
breakpoints following sequencing and
again looking at the chromosome
ideograms seeing the precision of the
prediction of the breakpoint by
cytogenetics and then fine line drawn
where the sequence analysis places the
breakpoint and the this is a case again
where the breakpoint fell in on both
derivative chromosomes in non-genic
regions so it turns out that we ended up
predicting that this phenotype would be
due to reduced sox9
expression we were able to do rtq PCR
and compare the expression in the CBS
sample cells from the CBS sample with
other CBS samples that were again agent
sex matched and the fetal MRI at 36 38
weeks and the postnatal findings
including small jaw index consistent
with micrognathia and rector nei Thea
and Glossip ptosis and cleft palate were
suggestive of isolated Pierre Robin
sequence and when we looked at the tab
analysis we found that sox9 was
downstream of the breakpoint in 17q at
band 24.3 and it's within the same 1.88
megabase tab with the breakpoints and
that's an area that is known to have
well known to have upstream this
regulatory region for expression of
Pierre Robin sequence associated with
sox9 dysregulation so the algorithm that
Cynthia
developed was able to make this
prediction that sox9 would be the likely
candidate
Jeane dysregulated in the in the
non-genic regions which were implicated
by the sequencing analysis and then
again you can see below our description
of the cytogenetic rearrangement at
nucleotide level precision so I just
like to summarize this presentation I
hope that you've you're coming away with
a sense that the the evaluation of genes
disrupted or potentially dysregulated at
chromosomal breakpoints truly requires
nucleotide level precision and this is a
precision that's now possible with the
application of all the technologies of
next-generation sequencing that tad and
haploinsufficiency analysis with
convergent genomic evidence may be
useful in assessing potential clinical
significance and in informing genetic
counseling we're able to that will allow
us to expand assessment of potential
positional effects whether this will be
possible in an actionable time frame for
prenatal diagnosis remains to be really
put into the the clinical pipeline but
it may not be possible certainly in all
cases to have that information as well
certainly the nucleotide level
resolution of the rearrangements is
possible in an actionable time frame for
prenatal diagnosis and I can assure you
that the rearrangements may be simple or
complex including those consistent with
chromothripsis in in the setting of
normal or array so thank you again for
watching today's live presentation if
you have a question you'd like to ask
please do so now just click on the
a question drop-down box located on the
far left of your presentation window
type your question into the box that
appears on your screen
and click the send button I will be
answering questions via email I like to
thank lab roots for making today's
educational webcast possible before we
go I want to let everyone know that
today's webcast will be available for
on-demand viewing through August 10th of
2018
you will receive an email from lab roots
letting you know when this webcast will
be available for replay please share
that announcement with your colleagues
who may have missed today's live event
that's all for now thank you for joining
us we hope to see you again goodbye